okay this is my second stream of today
first one is on Jeff's comm this was
this one's gonna be on me chess
it's a reddit chess tournament which
starts in just about 15 seconds I'm not
gonna play the whole thing but I'll play
some of it
try and get some least some interesting
blitz games in hello to Ariel hello
plaster hippie guys are joining just in
time two seconds left
apparently there's there's 420 players
according to Lee chess and question is
okay my opponent is here so let's play
some chess closest yulian let's play a
six I like to play this a six b5 line
a4 prevents that then I'll go for d5
it's gonna play d4 probably that's a
playable line a4 is a bit weakening so a
bishop you 7 I'll lose a tempo with the
bishop but hopefully it's not too
terrible let's play c4
okay complete development I'll go for a
knight c6 like knight c6 Knight d4 could
be an idea to make sure d5 is well
supported I'll play h6 preventing Bishop
g5
hello ref Raqqah hello you cook you got
chess toilet noggin with a tier 3 sub I
think that was done a little while ago
but I think maybe it just registered or
maybe he did it again
thanks for the noggin yeah tier 3 gives
you access to the the the rare emotes of
my face and of of GG the plan for the
stream for those of you who don't know
it's a reddit chess tournament or the
subreddit for chess organized this one
it's only chess it's a two hour long
event of three plus two it's actually
good to know I was playing three plus
zero earlier I was flying a lot of games
I'm not good at moving quickly at least
on chess comm let's play Bishop c5 if he
plays 94 I can take and then win c2
otherwise I'm threatening Queen b6 yeah
toilet noggin is one of my first tier 3
subs pretty sure I can still count the
tier 3 subs on one one hand so I'm
winning upon e 6 unexpected going for
counter play tempted to take in and take
on f3 I think I have to take
and maybe start with Queen g5 looks
reasonable attack the bishop
maybe preparing this or something like
this not sure how he's gonna defend the
bishop doesn't have too many squares if
you play rook e3 but then I play rook e8
and I'm up upon still so that's
reasonable with a Bishop d3 this reminds
me of drafts this nice formation
defending everything the only thing not
defended in my position is a6 pawn but I
don't care about a6 pawn also hello took
over good afternoon
even though it's 8 p.m. here more like
evening wait if it's afternoon where you
are you're in you're in Hawaii yeah
where would you be yeah rook III kind of
expected rook e8 for key Athan he plays
rook e1 wanna make d4 work somehow I
have a really cool combination idea I'm
gonna start with rook e8 he's gonna play
rook e1 and then I think I can take play
d4 wait okay rook e1 rook to e3 rook to
e3 d4 Queen take d4 rook take f3 Brooke
take f3 and I back rank mates think that
works which is maybe why he's hesitating
here I mean he could also be congest
considering taking that'll be a nice
tactic though if he actually plays rook
a e1
okay so he takes maybe he's watching the
stream he saw what's coming but I can
still okay I'm gonna still play rook f8
here try and get the same position
hoping for a rookie three which then
allows d4 otherwise okay yes to move the
bishop again or king h1 I guess I
probably shouldn't tell him all the best
moves rook D for a rookie five
unexpected I play this if he takes I
take I win if he takes the pawn I check
meet him this works
he's queenie one though yeah queenie
ones annoying okay I'll play Queen g6
just be solid some interesting tactics
this game maybe now he'll play rookie
three yeah I have a strong feeling he's
watching the stream he's just kind of
anticipating or he's listening to me
say all his best moves but I'm just up
upon here but how do I continue like to
play d4
Bishop e2 doesn't work
I have just started moving quicker in
the play queen not six not the most
exciting move but I think it's solid
I'll hold on to the extra pawn rather
hold on to the extra pawn his rook e8
rook e8 I should probably just stop
talking okay that was unexpected
d4 feels weakening let's do it because I
want to play Queen g5 next like rookie 7
Queen g5 and now I'm threatening this
and this and he's a long time except
Queen c1 probably isn't a threat because
rook e1 he's on the verge of flagging
this interesting move I play c5 probably
not let's just went up on now I'm up to
pawns his queen is active but not too
active his Queens tied down to the rook
Bishop takes c6 have to move much
quicker let's do this try and be solid
here this is the slowest time scramble
ever okay now I should be winning
ramping up the pace but how do I make
progress maybe h5
and then I can push okay yeah this is
winning now this f3 will fall there we
go hello to me flying toasters I can
take this right and then just push and
keep pushing and keep pushing until he
resigns there's a number of ways to win
this position this is probably the
easiest and then just promote okay tough
game slow time scramble at the end there
lots of tactics which he was avoiding
for the most parts stream suggestion
have a top donation section ah like on
on stream like in a graphic or just in
my twitch account because I would be I
think I have like a twitch panel on my
stream page which should show the top
donors but I'm not entirely sure how it
works also thanks for the host chess
coach net let me not not flag here and
thanks for the host of Fiona appreciate
that let's play this is actual rating
very secret cactus new Toby chess have
to be careful
okay so I'm just gonna try and play
quickly and solidly have a budapest rock
a six and rook h6 are some nice middle
game idea and I'm just gonna go for the
kill
like Queen d8 or Queen h4 is coming very
soon throw in c6 probably d6 soon and he
berserk so he doesn't have much time
can I take on h3 already I think I can I
think this is devastating GT gauge 3
Queen take h3 and made his coming if he
doesn't if he takes on e5 I think I can
get away with taking on g2
okay let's check on G - life is good
there's no stopping mate next move is
Queen h1 or Queen h2 unstoppable that's
why you shouldn't beserk in situations
like that so I'm in fourth place Wow
so he okay he was beserk in all his
games and he's still in first place
very secret cactus the 14 points
impressive so these games are rated I'm
playing another strong player I play
this guy the first game yeah I just
played him I'm playing him again have a
London he's playing quickly so let's try
and keep up the pace I have a mainline
Bishop b5 it's good he's starting to
think here Bishop d3 is like the most
main move Bishop b5 has been Carlson's
choice and it's um it's a nice move
there's lots of venom to it a six as far
as I understand is not a great approach
unless he's somehow really well-prepared
because okay I'm not gonna tell all my
secrets here because he might be
watching because last time the first
game I play them I was saying everything
and I feel like he was listening so if
you're listening you can wait until I
reveal all my secrets so that will be
after the game the problem for him is
now the the C pawn is weak and a move
like c5 will be punished I won't say how
it will be punished though I'll have to
play it to find out also thanks for the
comment will M Foley good to see you
here and hello to everyone else that
I've been ignoring hello chess with
Chris chess play chess match good to see
you okay he takes on g3
let me not get too distracted if he had
played c5 I had Queen a3 ideas
c5 right away looks like a free pawn
looks like a very free pawn
maybe I can swing over or put the Queen
on a3 he wants to play this move swing
the Queen yeah
I'll put the Queen on h4 and then go for
this attack because g4 g5 is not easy to
stop this h-file is I mean if I were him
I would be scared so he wants to win the
pawn I can start with this and h6 only
makes g5 stronger I think and g6 doesn't
really help because I have g4 in the end
he'll okay Kratz good to see you back so
I have a nice time advantage I don't
know what he's gonna play next so even
if he's watching he can't get help from
me
I mean 94 would be would be interesting
applying pressure I do want to make a
note for those of you who maybe have
been watching since the tournament began
Queen B 4 okay I'll have to delay my
notes so he's pinning my pawn I mean I
could still play g5 kind of like to play
a three a three Queens a p2 and then
rook b1 looks enticing
yeah I don't think his queen is gonna be
able to stay on the fourth-ranked
I could get in trouble with this move
because my King is also weak but I don't
see anything wrong with it
oh that's what's wrong with it I forgot
the pawn was just hanging so that's kind
of sad
well I'll play b4 and he has this move
this is not what I wanted
let's play rook h4 first this activates
view the H file c6 looks interesting
actually before it looks playable now
because I have a sneaky move if he plays
a5 should be very careful what I say
also I have ideas of taking and then
just stacking the exchange and playing
with my Knights let's start with this
because 9a 5 nice positional square
uh okay I'm not supposed to be reading
the chat but shout out to Matt's
daughter Lily hello Lily
thanks for watching I appreciate the the
viewership I don't appreciate g5 though
because g5 I just have to run away and
I've lost castling rights but at least I
have an outpost and now I should just
start focusing on playing quicker maybe
rook t1 I could also queenside castle
but that gets forked rook t1 attacking
the D pawn and now I can play kini 2
without worrying about the ship B 5 and
at some point I want to play f3 maybe
move my knight I don't know where let's
go here and go for f3 he's gonna play 9
h6
to up the tempo Knight g3 was the
threats he's gonna play h4 yeah and I'll
have a pretty night but it will just be
a decoration on g3 don't think it's too
harmful I would like to play e4 at some
points before now we trade
I feel like h3 is coming my knight is
out of the play speaking of decorations
so e4 we trade 93 rook e1 h3 is not
playable because a knight would be
hanging so let's go for it and I'll try
and infiltrate with like rook d6 do
something to the king the problem about
this position my Knights are not they're
not coordinating or as my old coach
would say they're not talking to each
other like they need to work together
here rook g6 is still interesting what
else do I do
d6 yeah I feel like I'm just worse here
because I have too many weak pawns might
be sevens nifty but doesn't accomplish
anything okay you might play this that
would be yeah that would be very hurtful
I mean this is also pretty painful what
do I even do here
I just have to okay King f3 Knight there
and survived if I was coming yeah this
is really bad
I'm still kind of alive if I get this
and get my rook to g7 that would be made
might be hard to accomplish I was a good
move
yeah he's on the verge of getting
revenge for the first game but I'm not
gonna give up I mean I like to fight
good move
I'm still not giving up because there's
there's tricks that I sometimes like to
poll
there's so many stale mating possibility
is it's so funny
take my rook oh that's not even
stalemate though
please Queen the number of possible
stalemates
no he did good he did a good job of not
walking into them where is this yeah if
he Queens here I could take a night take
that would also be stalemate
a good job to my opponent so I'm in 23rd
place that's unfortunate
hmm so tomorrow is a rest day the sink
filled Cup which means I have to make
plans have to make plans while playing
this tournament for either okay apex
attack let's play e4 let's try and be
aggressive I'll play play some kind of
grandpré attack I'll try and interact
with the chat even though it's sometimes
difficult
I can threaten mate in one please don't
see it
please don't see it he saw it okay but
now these Knights are weird I'm not
gonna play d4 to justify his knights
maybe I'll play b3 b3 Bishop b2 a very
strange place so far by both of us
I think the the plan should be to like
V&K doe and then decide where to castle
check out fine gold stream for a
donation graphic ah like the little
ticker thing that would be cool yeah I
think there's a way to do that I should
be more tech savvy when it comes to
streaming there there should be a way to
do that with like OBS I have been
exploring more options recently it's
just it's good to get feedback and input
from the viewers if anyone has any other
suggestions let me know be happy to take
feedback no joke in the chat this is not
a new mic this is a mic that I've I've
borrowed I've borrowed from a guy named
Mike okay I've Castle kingside do I play
King eh one typical typical Sicilian
move is my former coach used to say lady
three do you three is a nothing move has
no purpose it's just to make his time
tick and now I should probably start
thinking play Queen d2 and maybe 9191
let's play rugby one want to bring the
knight here black has more space but I'm
solid black just one connect for I love
that game there should be a leak connect
for org that should be like the next
edition and we could play out on like an
8x8 board it should be easy to code
right as a PI eight board but you need
some you need to code the gravity
is he gonna connect five he might buy
the things d5 okay I have some time and
managed a free app or program to learn
openings will be chess org I mean
they're they're opening Explorer is like
top-notch in my opinion that's easier to
use in chess base even though it has
slightly less functionality than chess
base it's just it's more accessible and
like you can especially with the leech
chess database you're referencing I
don't know what the exact number is
maybe no joke knows how many games does
elite chess database reference so I
usually tell my students like 70 or 80
million but it could be more it could be
less also the table base I still want to
make a youtube video about the table
base it's been on my to-do list
plenty okay
it's a specific number I can take and
rotate one actually okay one was
probably too passive should find ways to
get initiative here
so it doesn't have every single game
played on me chess fair enough okay my
opponents getting low on time less than
a minute that was unexpected but I guess
it's playable I'm inclined to take and
play 94 this is actually a solid set up
so you can never play e5 this pawn is
for every week if he plays a knight c6
okay that could get interesting I could
lead to a lot of trades that work on b1
it's all about making the pieces work
together finding some coordination some
activity maybe Bishop g4 this is his his
weak spot
rook b6 could be coming
I could attack the e pawn with four even
five more pieces let's play rugby six
I can win that pawn whenever I want I
just want to make him suffer I still
don't want to remove my night from d4 so
it's defending c2 so let's take maybe
all in the a pawn soon maybe I'll check
me at him soon just play this
about to flag okay he flagged was a
weird game very unusual opening and then
as something just went wrong for him
towards the end so I'm in 25th place I
do have to go soon but in the stick
around 20 good luck
maybe I should have dessert
sorry if I'm ignoring messages but I am
it's hard to keep up with everything in
the chat especially during these blitz
tournaments that's why usually when
people have questions you can respond to
each other
do you take c5 maybe Queen let's just
transpose he'll play e3 and then I'll
play this Wesley so line I admire the
streamers who can just like completely
zone out the chat Lucy take tea for this
is my preparation never seen anyone play
this against me 9h five is still the
move there's some really tricky lines
here though
then Queen b6 and there's some time
where we trade Queens and then okay rook
view ones not the most accurate move
let's play this no let's take first and
then play this because there's some
really interesting lines we're like can
sack the b-pawn and get a lot of counter
play
maybe Bishop d6 one of my problems is
when I do these streams I upload okay
90% of them to YouTube and then the
YouTube audience gets mad at me because
I'm interacting too much with a chat and
sometimes the twitch chat will get mad
at me without interacting enough so it's
hard to find the balance so I'm still
trying to figure that out
which is why probably I'll just end up
doing more YouTube exclusive content
also thanks for the follow I just
realized my thing is weird now anyone
who follows me in the future your name
should be visible
let's castle I have two bishops if I'm
not mistaken I still have a feedback
form to like people who want to give me
feedback you can go to my my twitch
panels and you can find the feedback
link and I still check it from time to
time Oh what is this let's just play e5
gain space he's playing really what's
what's a nice word passive is to mean
he's playing really solidly but he's
also just putting his pieces on bad
squares so it's just a sign that I
should be attacking there's a way to
display the chat on YouTube yeah I don't
think I'll display a chat on YouTube I
know other streamers do it I know Ben
Feingold does it but it's difficult
sometimes tricky to mod if there's
trolls and all my videos are supposed to
be kid-friendly so
yeah I think it's better to to not leave
the chats in the video when I make Queen
h4 happen I'll start with this
mmm so many enticing sacrifices let's
play Queen b6 the goal is to do this and
this okay I forgot defy was hanging but
should be okay
stocking a pawn for for open position to
make my bishops happy and to maybe sack
on e3 I'm probably threatening this
obviously threatening this if Queen d3
okay nevermind let's retreat I would
still like to capture here it's gonna
play Queen okay Queen h4 so there's some
calculation to be made take on you three
take on you three take on you three you
work out to 94 and 93 I take the rook I
win the bishop in the end so this should
be good okay now I just win the bishop
I'm attacking the rook the rook probably
has to move to one of these squares
which is really sad for whites okay
that's a move I didn't see maybe Knight
g4 no that leaves my rook attacked okay
I'll just went up on
there might be some ideas of Bishop g7
and 9f one do I dare play another phone
here oh let's play Bishop d7 first
because f king h2o now I play Knight of
fun and I want to win but it's not so
easy gonna take more work
probably the quickest way to win is is
fogging him unless I can made him on the
back rank please play 95 yes okay that
was an abrupt ending I'm still theory
the 23 night takeoff - did I miss
something probably did 23 in this
position night take F 2 also Queen f5
would have forked me
I think someone mentioned that that
would have been really painful then I
would just be down a piece Knight take F
- in this position yeah I mean I could
take on you 3 as 93 I was probably just
lazy to County I probably have something
like Bishop e4 which should be winning
but maybe I can survive gets a bit
tricky
okay back to tournament I'm still in
25th place I'll see if I can make it
till 9:00 without getting pulled away
between rounds I can look at the chat
but okay that was a very brief look at
the chat I'm gonna play a an opening
that I've been enjoying recently this a
three line because most people will play
Bishop c5 if there should be seven I
just play d4 and I'm happy
okay now I'm happier taking over the
center put the bishop here try and play
aggressively I'll probably Castle
queenside go for some attack
every attack usually starts with an H
pawn push okay not always but least in
this case he wants to play b5 okay I'll
play h5 and Queen d3 someday I would
light together Knight to g6 that might
be really difficult but it's possible
it's a really scary move it's actually a
really strong move to think I have to
play Bishop e3 yeah again I'm just
getting a bad position that's another
good news I'm losing material here that
was a really strong move Bishop g5 play
the Grob with the bits this is not the
time to get distracted
because my position so bad okay I'm
gonna bring I have to sack the exchange
and a pawn
I'll bring the Knight to f5 and try and
get counterplay Blackmoor Deemer I could
try and play that probably a good sign
that he's thinking here maybe a bad sign
he has countless ways to immaterial I'm
about to lose to a 1600 down the
exchange I'm down upon but these
physicians I don't give up always
flaking v1 and neither 5 will come knife
f5 will come he's managing his time too
ok let's play Knight a5 and g4 super
outpost he could play g6 but it's a bit
risky it opens up his King so we'll see
if he's brave enough to play it he plays
g6 what is going on here probably have
to go for this
this is not leading to anything
unfortunately his bravery paid off this
is really really bad
I have like just a couple tricks in the
position let's start with this I start
with that start with this
I mean my tricks will only work if he's
blundering so far I don't think he's
blundered he's playing a good game but
okay Knight is a trickiest piece on the
board
I should probably defend with this move
and then go for this
ooh he blundered okay life is better now
went from losing to winning one move I'm
just what I needed
nine is tricky but the Queen can be
tricky too
Oh do I go for that end game
I don't really want to calculate I'm not
gonna go for that in-game keeps a queen
and go for B 3 okay go for a 95
would like to organize some mating
attack with just like my queen and
knights not sure if it's actually
possible but like if I get an ID a
Knight to f6 a queen to h7 it could be
possible
Queeny sevens of threats at least an
idea okay
going in for the kill
I'm still looking for meat here Keeney
seven I check again the King keeps
running just take up on and make a new
queen there we go
that's so nice mate okay back to
tournament I'm in 20th place on a streak
just over an hour left I'm scrolling up
in the chat and seeing if I miss any
questions
can i play a Benoni or pirates I could
try to play Benoni or Pierre it's
depending when he plays let's play
Pierre it's an honor of Kover if you're
still watching where is a tournament
code know what you mean by turn in code
um maybe no joke could share the link
yeah no joke shared the link good job no
joke go for a 5 make the so Kings Indian
this is very common in the Pirates - -
just get this Kings Indian structure and
then go for some f5f or move a 5 might
take some preparation because if he
takes my night could be undefended in
this case I'm happy to find out at 4 and
then my Bishop will land on e5 my pawn
will come to h5 he's trying to close
down the King side but I feel like the
Kings side will open up very soon mmm
start by taking always play off 6 I'll
have a nice pawn diamond
maybe c6 if his King is running towards
the center I would like to I would like
to open the center I am playing
relatively quickly I mean there's a two
second increments so I gain time with
every move
let's sleep with pawn now I would like
to play rook h8 except she moves their
first improve the Bishop rook h8 is
still on the horizon and now there's
this this tension we're fighting for the
h-file
g5 I don't think I ever want to play f5
and g5 enables this Knight g6 9h for
idea and then then basically I can
forget about playing on the H file and I
can focus on the D file I'll have a
monster night on h4 okay so he takes and
h4 comes rook to e8 will come
[Music]
probably rook d7 Queen d8 is a plan so
nice nice position
I shouldn't maybe play the appearance
more often I'll start with this
okay I didn't see that move it's
annoying because Knight c5 is coming
let's move back wait night c5 is still
coming
what is this
strong move 97 was not so easy
thing is if he plays rook d1 I'm ready
for night g6 to bring in the Queen so he
has to be careful in the meantime I
still I still just want to play roof d7
and queens Yates interesting move I'm
going to start with Queen D eights and
then go for Queen b6 maybe rook d7
coming to get Queen b6
hmm still not easy but time situations
good the grating situation is good but
what to do
Queen c5 the threat is night take f3 I'm
expecting him to plunder a truck th
should be a blunder because I'm pretty
sure I'm getting away with this rook g8
I just do this I'm sorry for ignoring
the chats just it's easier to focus on
my game but hello hello to more people
Bend which is yeah King age 7
it's almost mate but not quite and my
threat is actually to take on c4 and
play 92 so good luck stopping that's
okay now I can take on c4 and take on g8
okay keeping the streak 14th place still
just over an hour left I'm getting
challenges for the people challenging me
I'm not taking challenges until until
sometime in the future but but yeah
someday so who's in first place 36
points a 1500 Wow let's buzzer to the
sky
he's 22 95 he's buzzer 'king back that's
very kind of him okay let's play London
mm display this line go for h4 h5 I'm
okay sacking material h6 okay his bishop
is sad I have a more normal position
than he does that was probably a good
move let's go for a bishop here if he
takes on me too I have this smooth
if you take some b2 I have this move now
mm-hmm just do this go for night c5 and
defend me 225 is met with c3 now before
maybe I like this position
rook see one night c5 will come take
away the night now it's the classic two
bishops versus two nights scenario those
dark squares could be weak throw in this
move if Queen b7 rook B b1 I'm just
keeping my time advantage probably
castle soon my king is safe on g1 or
maybe I'll play King f1 what to do
Bishop here want to do this
okay
don't really want to do that also my
time to move much quicker
double up on the e-file
when the night oh the night's defended
by two pawns why why did I not see that
with some hallucination there I still
might win this which could be a miracle
No
I I was hallucinating why did I think
the night was defend or undefended I
think I've it's just been too much Jess
maybe I was I was envisioning droughts
or drafts but still even if it was drops
he could like double jump me triple jump
me even okay one more game I have to
redeem myself
and then yeah and then I'll probably go
for dinner
mmm ping-pong tomorrow
actually am i play ping pong tonight
okay I'm playing the same guy let me
play let me play E for cuz I lost to him
before now I'm gonna play this tricky
line with a three make him think and
we're gonna play Knight to e5
this is my new pet line dozen I take e5
move I only learned it like very
recently guaranteed to make him think
and the point is it looks like white
sacking a piece but I'm just trying to
win a pawn because after Knight to g5
Queen e2 was this line yeah this line I
remember this I was informed about this
it gets weird
really liking the steam of playing weird
chess
I remember c3 c3 is a key move to
prepare d4 and I think it's reasonable
I'm just kind of an equal position I'm
gonna play this for a win somehow let's
go for a Bishop III g3 hey how's it
going this is my last game I'm yeah I'm
playing this tournament on me chess I'm
actually streaming right now so you can
say hi if you want to so all the twitch
audience they should recognize you
this is probably gonna be a draw should
be a draw have you seen this line before
this a3 and I take e5 no I learned it
the other day it's interesting
that's very Josh can you even offer a
draw but he's gonna try and beat me
because it's my pawns on dark squares
mmm okay let's take I just want to get
the King to d3 and play see for maybe I
could play for a win even yeah
I'm here I just taking d3c for
I'll have like two passers endgame
technique Bishop here okay don't help me
if you help me then they'll they'll get
mad I'm pretty sure I should be able to
to convert this unless there's some like
weird draw I hear in here
okay this could be a mistake but I'm
going for it
I'm making him think like if he if he
moves the bishop I'm happy if he takes
and at least my moves should be natural
mmm
can't take the bishop
so again okay so ideally I would like to
get a position where I make him play
this so I could put the bishop here so
Bishop f6 g4 I win if Bishop f6 h6 and I
play here he plays here it's tricky so
maybe I should run with my king first or
provoke h6 first he's offering a draw
which I'm not going to accept let's play
King d4 first there's some trick if he
does that I do that I just want to make
him stuck and I think it might be
important to give myself some extra
tempo let's start with this
because someday I want to win the g5
pond and then come back with the bishop
maybe that's some move just play a
waiting move I'm in no rush
ooh I forgot about that move oh let's
draw key for his winning really I forgot
he can make this threat I thought you
could play key for and then here and
then g4 yeah yeah probably best defense
was king g6 for him to fall king g6 but
I think you're winning anyway
wait this is this is a table based
position this is seven at seven pieces
this is drawn drawn after King e6 yes
but King c6 is losing yeah anyway I'm
ending it there thanks guys for watching
how many people are watching right now
let me see it should be away Oh close to
200 and been fine we'll just went live
okay we're gonna raid then fine gold so
raid what's this twitch name mm-hmm and
fine gold I think iam been fine gold
there we go
okay guys take care and have fun
watching Ben